alors évidemment vous choisissiez
génération d'antiquaires parce que ça
fait un certain moment que ce mouvement
s'est quand même imposé comme le
mouvement le plus efficace le plus
organisé le plus structuré en tout cas
qu'il était capable de faire face à
enfin tous ko nous opposant politique et
que nos actions sont efficaces mais on
voulait frapper au coeur de l'identité
titleist d'escautpont moi comme je vous
ai dit à la fois aux moi j'ai commencé
l'interview vous disant vous prenez pour
qui vous fait parfois et souvent des
actions où vous outrepassez vos droits
je suis désolé vous n'êtes pas ce que
maintenant est ce que je ne comprends
pas c'est qu'en fait tout simplement
nous ce que nous avons demandé au final
c'est justement nous respectons la loi
quand nous sommes allés au col du
portillon tout ce que nous demandions
c'était que la loi soit appliquée aux
migrants clandestins qui disent que
quand même
aux dernières nouvelles il faudra
réussir une frontière illégalement pas
que sa scierie de frontier et ça c'est
important
ou alors qu'un l'allergie vous reproche
pas d'avoir une opinion
vous avez le droit d'avoir une opinion
je la partage pas c'est une chose mais
vous avez le droit de la voir en
revanche l'incitation à la haine et
l'incitation aux açores parce que en
l'occurrence que j'ai le mien de racisme
ça en france l'inde est interdit c'est
interdit donc quand vous montez sur le
toit d'une mosquée pour scander des
slogans anti mi juillet juste mais il va
terminer mais se fait continuellement le
lien un lien direct des amalgames
volontaire entre d'islam les migrants et
le terrorisme ça c'est interdit ça
s'appelle de l'incitation à la haine et
c'est pour ça aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement dissout génération
identitaire ou en tout cas veut
dissoudre génération identitaire vous
avez dix jours pour répondre dans le
cadre d'une procédure contradictoire
en fait la démarche que vous voulez elle
est la même que lorsque le gouvernement
a dissout à baraka city ou le ccf parce
que dans deux genres très différents
vous prenez la haine est en sable fait
du mal à ce qu'est la république
française et à notre capacité à faire
société ensemble mais qu'on soit blanc
pierre d'un clair parlons on n'est pas
là non excusez-moi un délit de sale
gueule
vous vous avez une très bonne tête mais
c'est ce que vous dit en fait ce qui
pose problème c'est ce que vous dites
mais ce que vous faites
non mais c'est ça la longue balle et je
comprenais que vos actions
voilà c'est moi je moi ce que j'ai lu
tout à l'heure je suis dur est à venir
les propos racistes et au racisme qu un
délit en france
voilà c'est tout donc
non mais je l'espère je m'attendais
effectivement à ce que vous disiez ça
néanmoins si vous voulez effectivement
nous dissoudre pour incitation à la
haine raciale un discours c'est une
conviction mais si vous voulez nous
disent oui pour incitation à la haine
raciale comme vous le dites il faut
bouger les audigier les outils
juridiques pour le faire on est d'accord
néanmoins lorsque nous avons occupé le
chantier de la mosquée de poitiers donc
l'action dont vous parlez nous n'avons
eu aucune condamnation n'avons pas été
condamné l'accusation à l'aise vous êtes
monté à bobigny sur la caisse
d'allocations familiales en criant pas
d'argent pour les étrangers il se trouve
que la procédure est encore entier a eu
19 condamnations je crois à trois mois
de sursis
mais ce n'était pas pour une incitation
à la haine raciale en l'occurrence c'est
parce que nous défendions évolué chez
moi à kayes à sion le slam hors d'europe
on est chez nous vous trouvez ça normal
ça c'est pas possible
dice thaïs vous là vous jouez sur les
mots je suis désolé vous n'avez pas été
condamné pour ça mais vous voyez que
vous êtes hors la loi juste pas
brillamment la loi mais nous n'avons pas
été condamnés le débauchage de la
justice la justice a tranché nous avons
été relaxé pour notre eau notre
opération dans les alpes nous n'avons
pas été condamné pour l'occupation du
chantier de la mosquée de poitiers en
l'occurrence et tous les autres motifs
qu'il s'appelle denis muzet dans la
lèvre conseil vient à vous avez le droit
de le faire oui mais oui tout à fait
nous avons pas très mobile aurait sondé
front national le fait est que si jamais
vous obtenez une autre solution
vous n'avez pas les outils juridiques
pour le faire sur